hello and welcome to the video play fmz
amar moot field master okay so and let's
see backing this netherlands right looks
like the netherlands yes em so let's go
for a bank Oh see what he is up to yeah
sofa leave the most critical line is to
take it actually quite far the most
critical line that correct English
probably not but so we probably get the
pillow which here no egos g3 okay the g3
line is actually extremely harmless
against them against this particular
setup because the most dangerous setups
with an early would be one now don't
make any sense I get Bishop f5 in here I
don't take on a six unless I have to
let's see how what we would we get
castles probably Knight b6 and then
White has a choice how to proceed Ruby 1
and T form is a plan we'll see what he
does even taking with the night is an
option something that I have tried in
England's chest but the best is to just
play it like I just just do delay the
capture h4 h4 sorry for the sound I too
won't be something to drink yeah I don't
know don't quite believe in those things
but why not go age 5 just stop
everything there
in most cases it will be rather
favorable for me that I have g4 as a
square his life coming to g5 is a little
bit mysterious okay so let's do this
prevent any BB 3 okay let's see does he
do is there anything direct technically
that you can do you like on the light
squares like fy5 things like that I'm
sure don't think so okay currently I'm
threatening night a 3m the pretty
substantial idea ok I can do do you I
would have played 93 anyway now white is
just losing yeah that's the upside of an
opening like this Ian if it goes wrong
for white it goes really really wrong
I mean on the other side the other hand
if it was a bomb for black you can you
can also say that the opposite might
also happen okay I can take it to as
well if I like it I don't don't know
like for loop you one but I think rather
picking picking this up is better okay
where to go 95 I guess if it takes this
item minded much
and it's pretty pretty bad I think he
will take though
maybe roxy warner trying to pick up this
pawn so i am just cover it on cover this
bishop if i trade rook it will be
technically very easy to win so I'm
going to try that one can also play yeah
this is also not bad just cover this
horn and see then I get around to d3 and
then get this you check down the board
we should be 30 that's a good news if I
can can get it in maybe place 91 or
something like that I mean it's all very
scary but still ok and then g6 but it
should not should not promote weight
it's not let's not blender it
okay white person tonight yeah it was a
real opening disaster um yeah as
mentioned i think the g3 line is
entirely harmless he and the reason is
that after the normal continuation like
this white normally wants to play a set
up with rook b1 b3 and Bishop b2 if he
can get it in or Bishop d2 but he wants
to play b3 to prevent me from going to
c4 and b3 immediately of course doesn't
work because i have a tactic on the
diagonal so the logical move would be
would be one and it doesn't make any
sense because i have this now he has to
go back and this render society a
completely useless and this is a big
problem for white what he usually does
is he switches to this kind of setup but
here black is extremely active also
that's I think a very nice position for
black OKH for its kind of hmm I don't
know this is a simple reply and now 95
this is all a little bit mysterious if
you ask me okay so one night see form
yeah I can actually switch the touches
on but it's not very interesting black
always has very good compensation here
the engine is giving why the slight edge
but the theory doesn't mean much for
example Queen 84 is a completely wacky
move what what is that doing nobody
plays a move like ranae for ya anyway
this is what he did and now I'm
threatening 93 which is funny he
basically just handed me this I would
have played 983 anyway if you play
like this I mean this is just not very
good yeah the engine actually wants to
do this and with this Fred yeah it's
good anyway here White has to play some
strange move to keep the balance or 96
oh this is interesting and this is
something as I said yeah does he have
something damn this is funny very very
weird line takes cakes Wow
hmm computer gives me a slight edge but
this is the kind of position where you
probably need a little bit more
calculation depth it looks a bit scary
for me if you ask me yeah that's the
critical moment probably this is the
other move that that you can play I
think blank should be okay in a
situation like that yeah auntie em here
wide is just to blend out dueling losing
everything now as I said during the
actual game and if it goes wrong for
right it goes really really wrong ok
guys thanks for watching